[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
putting it together that's what a
director does he or she takes the many
diverse elements that go into making a
motion picture and tries to put them on
the screen in a way that touches
people's hearts and minds it's always a
challenge sometimes a burden and
ultimately a privilege but it's not an
easy task a director needs the stamina
of an athlete and the patience of a
saint a director is part artist part
politician part father confessor and
part Jewish mother
directing is a constant battle to get
the best from yourself and the best from
your collaborators it's a fight against
the weather against the schedule against
the budget sometimes you dine on success
and sometimes you simply eat crow but
all the time you are following a vision
and wonder of wonders sometimes that
vision comes true Franco Zeffirelli who
was nominated for Romeo and Juliet sent
a cable to Stanley Kubrick who was
nominated that same year for 2001 they
both lost by the way Zeffirelli wrote
you made me dream eyes wide open it's
time now to honor the nominated
directors for the dreams they've given
us this year the nominees are hector
babenco for kiss of the Spider Woman
[Applause]
[Music]
Sydney [ __ ] four out of Africa
[Applause]
John Huston for Prizzi's honor
[Applause]
[Music]
akira kurosawa four on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Peter we're for witness
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner is memories
Sydney Papa
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much Frank price made
this film possible he had the courage
when it mattered the most and was easy
to say no I knew it was impossible to
get a screenplay from this material so I
didn't try Kurt lucky didn't know it was
impossible and so he did it David Ray
feel kept us honest Merrill Bob Klaus
and Malick brought those characters to
life and made an incredible world all of
us being helped all the time by Terry
Clegg who kept us going I had a team of
editors who locked themselves in a room
with me seven days a week 12 hours a day
and behaved as though nothing else in
the world existed John Barry made it all
sing Karen Blixen lived that life turned
it into art and taught a generation a
new way to write prose my wife Claire
gave me more encouragement then I have
any right to have put up with more was
more tolerant I'm dented to all of them
I can't leave this podium without saying
I could not have made this film without
Meryl Streep she is astounding
personally professionally in all ways
and I can't thank her enough
[Applause]
[Music]